les chevaux du soleil ou encore le vase
de la paix voilà ce que vous pouvez
découvrir à versailles
la galerie des sculptures et des
moulages ouvre exceptionnellement ses
portes au public jusqu'au 27 décembre
une installation accueillis dans la
petite écurie du roi sur place plus d'un
millier d'oeuvres de quoi marquer les
visiteurs le col la colle le alexandre
sais pas il fait au moins 5 m 2 de
hausse
cet apollon c'est alexandre c'est
vraiment aussi il paraît et alexandre
qui fait cinq minutes j'y mets comment
ils ont amené vraiment c'est magnifique
l'occasion de voir des moulages du musée
du louvre d'après l'antique ou encore
des sculptures originales des jardins du
célèbre château les trois quarts ont été
copiés au cours du temps puisqu'elle se
sont abîmés
finalement avec des intempéries en
particulier et puis c'est l'occasion de
les voir grandeur nature et puis elles
s'offrent à nous finalement avec le
grain du marbre original qu'elles ont
l'installation a attiré amateurs et
passionnés pour certains à l'été
l'occasion de mieux percevoir louis xiv
mais aussi de visualiser l'art de vivre
à l'époque baroque le canon de beauté en
fait surtout féminins et masculins qu'on
voyait à l'époque de louis xiv fut que
on reprend l'art antique et on reprend
la mythologie vu que louis xiv en plus
se démarque en apollon dieu du soleil
des arts et de la danse la galerie des
sculptures et des moulages sera ouverte
au public tous les week ends jusqu'au 27
décembre